.
♪ J'habite le 76,
coin 7
- Luc De Larochellière a grandi
sur cette rue du quartier
Laval-des-Rapides.
- Çois.
- Et c'est ici, dans sa maison
d'enfance, qu'il a écrit
"Sauvez mon âme". De sa fenêtre,
il a éd'en face.
♪ Il roule dans la Cadillac
de Dieu ♪
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- Oui, oui, ils étaient rentrés
dans une... dans... appelons ça
une secte religieuse, n'est-ce
Cadillac qui stationnait là
des fois. Et bon, l'image, quand
je parlais du pasteur qui roule,
c'est ça, dans la Cadillac de
Dieu, c'était devant la po
♪ Moi, je viens d'une ville
entourée d'eau ♪- C'est après êé
dans son ancien quartier que
Luc De Larochellière a imaginé
en 15 jours son album-concept
un album composé de 12 nouvelles
chansons où il rend hom
à Laval et à son pont Viau.
♪ Des boulevards
et des patinoires ♪
♪ Et puis un
- Justement, le flash dela chan,
ça m'est venu en traversant
ce pont-là à pied.
♪ Moi, j'suis né du bon bord
Du bord de l'Amérique ♪
Rendu au métro au Henri-
Bourassa, j'avais "Amère
America" dans la tête, puis
je me suis dit : OK, je pe OK, e
qu'il y a quelque chose à faire
avec ça.
- Dans "Rhapsodie lavalloise",
il est question entre autres
d'un vge banane,
d'un enfant sauvé de la noyade
et de l'Amérique française
de l'an 1976.♪ Et tout est beau
dans l'Amérique française ♪
- C'est les origis,
le rêve américain, j'en parlais
dans... je le nommais dans
la chanson "Chinatown blues",
je parlais du petit gars
de banlieue, qui,
finalement! Moi, je suis né du
bon bord, du bord de l'Amérique,
d'une ville tranquille,
où e matin...e matin...e matin..
Bien, c'était ici. T'sais,
c'était ici. Je le nommais pas
à l'époque parce qu'il y avait
toujou chose d'un peu,
je veux dire, péjoratif aussi,
t'sais, puis de toutes les
banlieues, on dirait que Laval,
c'étai
♪ Par un lundi sans histoire
un peu beige, un peu rasoir ♪
♪ Henri c'est extirpé du lit ♪
- Luc De Larochellière a écrit
"Rhapsodie lavalloise"
en pleine pandémie et
en partie pour ses enfants.
Il y a un devoir de mémoire.
- Je suis père deux fois,
j'ai été père assez jeune,
fin vingtaine, de ma fille
Claudelle, et à 50 ans
tout juste, j'ai eu un enfant.
Donc à 55 ans, je vis avec
un enfant aujourd'hui, je voisse
devant mes yeux et ça m'a ramené
à la mienne.
- Avant de quitter à nouveau
Laval pour Montréal,
Luc De Larochellière a laissé
son magnifique album-concept
à la propriétaire de la maison
où tout a commencé.
- Merci beaucoup, ça me fa
drôle de voir ça ici, ça me fait
bien drôle. Ça, ça a pas changé,
c'était là, c'était pareil!
- Il y a bien des choses
qui ont pas changé ici.
♪ J'habite le 76,
coin 7
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Laval.
♪ Sur un pâté de maisons
qui somes ♪
♪ Mon père est une p